i was like oh my god beyonce i don't
remember
i was like taking me like maybe like two
or three times like the next
day and the day after that and i was
like crying friends with beyonce y'all
need to be talking to me
do you know it's her the moment you hear
her signature phrase
after the beat drops the world knows her
as megan the stallion but
she was born megan jovan ruth pete on
february 15
1995 in the lone star state we're really
putting on for houston right now
this houston native lit up social media
with
pure musical fire releasing viral hit
big old freak big booty big old tree
after hit i'm a savage
her rise to the top is remarkable with 5
top 10 billboard hits over 600 million
streams on spotify
and 14 million followers on instagram
solidifying her status as one of the top
female rappers in the game
and right now this is her moment
i did i did what i had to do we had a
hot girl year
and we still dragging it out so yeah
megan's love for music came at an early
age
she was inspired to follow in the
footsteps of her mother and fellow
rapper
holly thomas aka hollywood my
mom was a rapper ever since i could
remember
she would have me in the waiting room in
the studio but i'm like at the door like
listening like okay
yeah yeah her career may be hotter than
ever now but
it really started in 2016 when she
stepped up as the only female rapper
in the houston cipher rap battle laying
the foundation for a climb
so fast even nasa would be jealous
[Music]
one short year later in 2017 megan found
the power in her voice with her first
mixtape
rich ratchet rhyming over beats like
jay-z's classic
big pimpin
[Music]
and how about this for a plot twist she
was doing all of this while still
finishing her college degree at texas
southern university
i'm not going to let music distract me
from school
i'm not going to let school distract me
from music 2018 would become megan's
breakout year
she signed to a local houston record
label established a fan base
she calls hotties hi hotties and
dropped the tina snow ep owning every
single
x-rated verse she put on wax freakness
in 2019 big ole freak started trending
after megan dropped the single
and challenged the hotties to a twerking
contest online
[Music]
i'll teach you how to play i'm the high
girl coach i can teach you everything
you need to know
the song the challenge and megan picked
up steam
and her life changed forever i'm busy
every day
i'm literally on the move every day some
i don't even know what day it is
honestly
she kept that hot streak going racking
up some impressive award
noms and wins with bet billboard
and mtv she also graced the cover of
some of the most popular magazines
it just really blows my mind every day
like when i write music or when i'm like
rapping i'm not really thinking
oh my gosh it's going to go crazy like
i'm just making it because i like it
lock down endorsement deals with coach
and revlon and just last year megan had
every woman feeling like they were
having a hot girl summer
it's a hot girl fast forward to early
2020
megan continued her social media streak
taking tick-tock by
storm with viral dance challenges from
her hit single savage
later remixing the song with her idol
beyonce to a certified billboard hit
like i have been speaking it into
existence like i want to do something
with beyonce i want a song
beyonce but literally of the sky blue it
came like beyonce is going to do this
and i was like
and did we mention megan's got some
other a-list bffs too
like nicki minaj kylie jenner and lizzo
this is my girl
and we're both from texas the flu and
texas just hyping each other up that
female empowerment yes i love lizzo
just like every huge mega superstar
megan has had to deal with a little bit
of controversy along the way
a night of partying in hollywood ended
with the raptors being
seriously injured i was shot in both of
my feet
and i had to get surgery
to get the taken out get the bullets
taken out
and it was super scary it's like just
the worst experience of my life
i didn't deserve to get shot and do
megan initially kept the details of what
happened
under wraps until recently on instagram
live
she named the person who she says shot
her
yes this tory shot me
you shot me and you got your publicist
and your people
going to these blogs lying
stop lying tori has yet to respond to
the allegations
i mean everybody has a different path
megan didn't let the drama get in the
way though
she dropped her most recent success [ __ ]
a sex positive collab with cardi b
which debuted at number one on the
billboard hot 100
the song broke multiple records
including being the most streamed song
in its first week ever by a female
artist
even tiger king's carol baskin couldn't
look away
and get this megan announced plans to
perform a live virtual concert
her first headlining show since the
pandemic is this happening
megan has set her sights on not just
taking over the rap game but the
entertainment world
her personality was on full display on
season one of the ballroom voguing
competition
legendary and she's expected back as a
judge for season two
he basically explained to me what it was
i like looked up everything i knew about
ballroom on youtube and i'm like yes
i want to do this like i just really
thought it would be a really cool thing
and like really
it was inspirational to me because i see
everybody performing and going so hard
like they made me want to be better
performers so i really wanted to be a
part of the world
like really understanding what ballroom
is we see you megan the stallion
keep on rising to the top from the top
make it drop that's some wet and cause
she not get a [ __ ] in a mob
that's some wet and